[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka nun abend wenn
bundeskanzler scholz tatsächlich bald
nach kiew reist weiß er auf welche
erwartungen er dort trifft ein klares
bekenntnis zur ukraine eine eindeutige
positionierung das hat präsident des
elends die heute noch einmal deutlich
gemacht im interview mit christian
sievers in kiew kritisierte er die
deutsche regierung nehme nach wie vor zu
viel rücksicht auf russland
olaf scholz hat sich dazu heute auch
geäußert angesprochen auf kritik dass
deutschland bislang keine schweren
waffen geliefert habe sagte er
deutschland werde liefern was es
zugesagt habe aber für schweres gerät
wie die haubitzen oder den geparden
bräuchte es vorher ausbildung sonst sei
das keine effektive hilfe dass die
ukraine dringend waffen benötigen ist
auf den schlachtfeldern im süden und im
donbass allenthalben zu sehen im moment
sind die russischen angreifer dort im
vorteil aller kreise berichtet
ein kampf um jeden meter der stadt
bilder davon gibt es kaum diese hier
zeigen häuserkämpfe in sie vier oder
netz vom wochenende heute meldet die
ukrainische armee verluste sie sei aus
dem zentrum verdrängt worden auch das
industriegebiet der stadt steht unter
schwerem beschuss auf dem gelände der
süd chemie fabrik sollen sich nach
ukrainischen angaben etwa 500 zivilisten
aufhalten alle brücken zur nachbarstadt
lang und zerstört die verteidiger und
den zivilisten ist so der fluchtweg
abgeschnitten
die russische armee ist im osten auf dem
vormarsch trotz großer gegenwehr
russland veröffentlicht heute bilder von
erbeuteten systemen zeigt angriffe auf
waffenlager und meldet ein depot zu
haben
zerstört wurde eine große anzahl von
waffen und militärischer ausrüstung die
für ukrainische nationalistische gruppen
geliefert wurden unter anderem aus den
usa und europäischen ländern überprüfen
lässt sich das nicht trotz der verluste
das ziel der ukraine bleibt unverändert
russlands niederlage dafür gefordert
dringend mehr schwere waffen konkret
luftabwehrsysteme hunderte panzer und
geschosse denn
der feind ist uns in bezug auf
ausrüstung und artillerie weiterhin
zahlenmäßig überlegen die
verteidigungskräfte kämpfen aktiv und
fügen den feinden hohe verluste zu der
preis für diesen kampf ist hoch von
12.000 getöteten zivilisten seit beginn
des kriegs spricht der chef der
ukrainischen polizei jeder kann
jederzeit sterben ist der titel des
aktuellen berichts von amnesty
international
darin stuft die organisation den
russischen angriff auf die stadt im
norden der ukraine als kriegsverbrechen
wir haben sieben fälle gefunden in denen
streumunition in bewohnten gebieten von
hfv eingesetzt wurde diese angriffe
waren verheerend
auch die ukraine habe gegen völkerrecht
verstossen indem artillerie in der nähe
von wohngebäuden positioniert wurde
wieder moskau noch kiew haben den
bericht kommentiert aus kiew kam die
ansage frühere waffenlieferungen hätten
zerstörungen wie hier in borodjanka und
zivile opfer verhindern können vor einem
möglichen besuch von bundeskanzler
scholz erhöht die ukraine den druck was
deutschland bisher an waffen geliefert
hat reicht dies nicht aus
und dann schalten wir live nach kirschs
christian ein interview mit einem
staatschef im krieg ist jetzt auch nicht
das was man alle tage führt
ja das stimmt marietta guten abend aus
kiel vor einer stadt in der es auch
heute wieder raketenalarm gab und
gleichzeitig das sommerliche leben
weiter ging weil alle darauf hoffen dass
es auch diesmal fehlalarm ist so etwas
muss man sich die lage auch im
präsidentenpalast vorstellen dass es
dieser mammut bau den sie hinter mir
sehen können aus sowjetzeiten schwer
bewacht und stark gesichert vor den
fenstern in den gängen überall sandsäcke
es gibt kaum licht und es macht wirklich
beklommen details der
sicherheitsmaßnahmen dort dürfen nicht
veröffentlicht werden und das werden wir
jetzt auch nicht tun in den büros sieht
man auf jeden fall schuhe man sieht t
shirts feldbetten weil viele mitarbeiter
diesen bau seit über 100 tagen nur noch
selten verlassen können kontrast dazu
das lagezentrum oder präsident seine
internetauftritte macht er meldet sich
ja nach wie vor jeden tag bei seinem
volk hier achten die jungen mitarbeiter
sehr auf die optik der raum wirkt wie
das büro eines hippen
internet-startups niemand trägt anzug
niemand trägt krawatte viele haben ringe
unter den augen wegen der durchwachten
nächte dort habe ich heute mittag mit
rotem ihr selensky gesprochen
herr präsident sie sie lieben und sie
arbeiten hier in ihrem amtssitz
verbarrikadiert hinter hinter sandsäcken
gleichzeitig sind sie jeden tag präsent
über social media bei ihren landsleuten
und die ganze welt kennt sie
mittlerweile sie sind berühmt der name
selensky sagt quasi jedem auf dieser
welt etwas was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
wie hat dass die situation für sie
persönlich verändert
es fällt mir schwer ihre fragen gefasst
worden war das sage ich ganz aufrichtig
vieles hat sich geändert die werte ich
habe mich verändert unsere bürger haben
sich verändert das wichtigste ist in
unseren herzen als priorität geblieben
familie kinderstadt frieden in diesem
staat das sind die wichtigsten werte
der us präsident joe biden hat jetzt
gerade gesagt er habe schon viel früher
gewarnt vor einem russischen angriff auf
die ukraine aber auch sie hätten es
nicht hören wollen haben sie
rückblickend etwas das sie anders machen
würden wenn sie zurückschauen
ich glaube dass die ukrainische seite
eine frage stellen sollte um diese frage
sollte an viele europäische staatschefs
sowie an den amerikanischen staatschef
gerichtet sein
es wäre gerecht wenn man auf mich als
ukrainischen staatschef im voraus gehört
hätte wo vorher gewarnt haben ich meine
präventiv sanktionen damit der krieg
nicht beginnt die präsentation unserer
strategie bezüglich des schwarzen meeres
des
aufbaus der schwarzmeerflotte mit einem
partnerland
wir haben das vorgeschlagen wir haben
gesagt dass russland das schwarze meer
blockieren wird
wir haben auch über das raketenprogramm
gesprochen ich habe vor einem jahr
darüber berichtet und das programm
präsentiert was wir an luftverteidigung
bräuchten uns zu schützen und das ist
die richtige antwort auf ihre frage
wenn man mich doch gehört hätte hätte
die ukraine mehr chancen die invasion
der russischen föderation aufzuhalten
die signale die sie ansprechen sie waren
alle unterschiedlich schauen sie mal
wenn alles so passiert wäre wenn alle
die ukraine gewarnt hätten dass es
morgen zu einer flächendeckenden in
version kommt so stellt sich die frage
warum wurde der luftraum nicht
geschlossen warum wurden uns keine
waffen vor dieser invasion geliefert und
warum wurden keine vorläufigen
sanktionen eingeführt so dass der
präsident russlands präventiv
aufgehalten wird
so würde ich das beantworten lassen sie
uns ehrlich sein wir haben uns darauf
selbst vorbereitet am anfang hat uns
niemand unterstützt und nun bin ich
allen partnern dafür dankbar dass wir
unterstützung bekommen hat
dieser technisch betreut warum ist die
beziehung zwischen bundeskanzler olaf
scholz und ihnen so kompliziert
ich glaube es gibt eine gewisse skepsis
in der beziehung der führung
deutschlands der ukraine gegenüber
ich glaube nicht dass diese skepsis auf
bundeskanzler scholz zurückzuführen ist
ich glaube nicht dass sie neu ist
weil ja was ich glaube wir haben
wunderbare beziehungen zwischen beiden
völkern und recht gute beziehungen
zwischen den führungen beider staaten
aber ich glaube diese skepsis kommt vor
allem zum ausdruck wenn es um die
künftige mitgliedschaft der ukraine in
der eu und der nato geht diese skepsis
war leider auch in der zeit von
bundeskanzler scholz zu spüren es gab
diese haltung und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass sich diese haltung ändern wird
sowie das gerade aussieht
[Musik]
vielleicht würde es helfen wenn der
bundeskanzler tatsächlich nach kiew
kommt das will er jetzt in kürze bereits
tun er sagt immer wieder er möchte nicht
einfach zu einem fototermin kommen und
sie zu besuchen ich nehme mal an das
sehen sie ganz ehrlich was konkret
müsste es denn dann seien bei diesem
besuch mehr als nur fotos
und wir möchten auch nicht dass er nur
zu einem fototermin kommt
er meint wohl wir hoffen auf die
militärische unterstützung der ukraine
seitens deutschlands
ich glaube er meint dass darüber hinaus
erwarte ich dass er uns persönlich
unterstützt und dass er persönlich
zuversichtlich ist dass die ukraine der
eu angehören kann und dass der status
eines beitrittskandidaten der ukraine
bereits im juni verliehen
wir rechnen eher damit ich rechne er
damit dass herr scholz diese zuversicht
in seiner antwort zum ausland
es gibt aber auch die frage der
sanktionen die finanzielle unterstützung
die die ukraine braucht und alle
sicherheitsfragen mit denen er sich
bestens auskennt
was erwarten wir im zusammenhang mit
seinem besuch ich würde gern das
folgende wichtige anliegen präzisieren
wir brauchen von kanzler scholz die
zuversicht dass deutschland die ukraine
unterstützt er seine regierung müssen
für sich selbst entscheiden
keine balance zwischen der ukraine und
der beziehung zu russland zu suchen
sondern
man muss für sich wählen wo man die
prioritäten
doch ich glaube das deutsche volk hat
das für sich selbst schon entschieden
in der führung fällt es schwer denn es
gibt viele verschiedene
herausforderungen
das kann ich nachvollziehen
der mensch ja diagnose nazareth niemand
liefert waffen in ähnlich großem umfang
wie deutschland das tut an die ukraine
sagt der bundeskanzler
stimmt das aus ihrer sicht
management betrieb steht ehrlich gesagt
der ist deutschland etwas später als
einige unserer nachbarländer dazu
gekommen was die waffenlieferungen
angeht das ist eine tatsache
das ist nicht nur rhetorik sondern auch
eine tatsache die ersten die uns zu
helfen begonnen haben hat waren die usa
die slowakei polen großbritannien das
waren die ersten die geliefert haben
bulgarien und rumänien haben auch
geholfen es ist klar warum das so
gekommen ist
auch baltischen staaten sie gehörten zu
den ersten unter diesen staaten in
europa waren deutschland und frankreich
etwas später dran und das ist die
wahrheit sie haben die ukraine
unterstützt sie haben gleich erklärt
dass dies eine verletzung der
souveränität darstellt politisch haben
sie das gleich mitgetragen aber damals
am anfang des krieges brauchten wir
nicht politiker sondern hilfe
politik anschließend kamen andere
staaten dazu und gott sei dank dass sie
dazu gekommen sind und uns helfen was
den umfang an gelieferten waffen angeht
bin ich nicht bereit die aussagen zu
bestätigen die sie eben gemacht haben
ehrlich gesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher
die zahlen
hat die ukraine aktuell an der front
sehr hohe verluste mich würde
interessieren wie sie diese sehr sehr
schwierige entscheidung treffen
sie könnten ja auch sagen wir ziehen die
front ein wenig zurück dann müssten sie
möglicherweise gebiete abtreten auf der
anderen seite könnten sie vielleicht
verluste ein weniger vermeiden ist das
etwas was in ihrem kopf jede nacht jeden
tag abgewogen werden muss oder wie gehen
sie damit um
sie haben mit einer privaten frage
darüber angefangen wie ich mich geändert
habe wie sich alles geändert hat
nun beantworte ich diese frage auch an
dieser stelle
ich habe keine zweifel dass wir korrekt
an
und das ist das wichtigste
die veränderungen die ein präsident zu
friedenszeiten durchmacht und die ein
präsident zu kriegszeiten durchmacht
da darf es keine zweifel geben gar keine
man muss handeln die zeit spielt dem
feind und nicht uns in die hände
was ist die wahrheit die wahrheit ist
wir sind auf dem eigenen boden das ist
unser volk
das ist unser territorium
denn das tut sehr weh menschen zu
verlieren das ist so aber wir werden
alles verlieren wenn wir russland in
diesem krieg unterlegen sind
das wichtigste was mich von mir früher
unterscheidet ist ich suche keine
balance doch wie man eine balance findet
um irgendwie zu einem abkommen zu
gelangen wir wissen genau was wir tun
ich betone wir haben keine zweifel wir
sind nur dann bereit gespräche zu führen
denn die andere seite bereit ist dem
krieg ein ende zu setzen wir haben keine
zeit für gespräche die nichts bringen
tradorias
präparieren und da präsident lenski
vielen dank für das gespräch
danke auch kommen sie auch in frieden
nach kiew aber dass sie im krieg hier
sind ist ebenso wichtig und so ist es
auch wichtig und dass bundeskanzler
scholz im krieg hierherkommt
das interview in voller länge können sie
in der zdf mediathek sehen selensky ein
präsident der erkennbar damit hat dass
er jetzt zum kriegspräsidenten wurde ich
habe so wenig zeit den satz hat er uns
heute immer wieder gesagt er ahnt auch
für einen friedens präsidenten gäbe es
hier in der ukraine viel zu tun maria
tölle morgen meldest du dich dann
nochmal aus kiew und dann mit einem
gespräch mit bürgermeister witali
klitschko bis dahin auf wiedersehen nach
christian
und wie gesagt das ganze interview mit
präsident selensky können sie online
ansehen auf ze erfreute und dort gibt es
natürlich auch noch jede menge
hintergrund berichte und analysen zum
krieg in der ukraine
und hier macht jetzt aber erstmal heinz
wolf weiter mit anderen nachrichten
dieses tages das ausmaß sexualisierter
gewalt an kindern und jugendlichen im
katholischen bistum münster er ist einer
unabhängigen studie zufolge deutlich
größer als bisher bekannt im
untersuchungszeitraum von 1945 bis 2020
seien nachweislich 610 jungen und
mädchen opfer sexualisierter gewalt
durch etwa 200 geistliche geworden so
die forschergruppe der uni münster die
studie geht von einer hohen dunkelziffer
von bis zu 6.000 missbrauchten kindern
aus und der münsteraner bischof genn
will sich am kommenden freitag zu der
studie
zwischen großbritannien und der eu droht
neuer streit über die zoll regelung für
nordirland die mb exit abkommen
vereinbart wurde die britische regierung
will änderungen und hat dazu heute einen
gesetzentwurf ins parlament in london
eingebracht so sollen die waren
kontrollen zwischen nordirland und dem
restlichen großbritannien durch eine
freiwillige regelung ersetzt werden die
eu seite reagierte sofort eine
neuverhandlung des nordirland protokolls
komme nicht in frage
die zahl der atomwaffen in der welt
könnte nach einem jahrzehntelangen
rückgang laut der einschätzung von
friedensforscher bald wieder zunehmen
sowohl in den usa als auch in russland
liefen umfassende und kostspielige
programme um die atomsprengköpfe
trägersysteme und produktionsstätten
auszutauschen und zu modernisieren ist
es heute bei der vorstellung des neuen
jahresberichts des stockholmer
friedensforschungsinstitutes sipri
russland und die usa verfügen sie prix
zufolge über rund 90 prozent aller
atomsprengköpfe in der welt
erst dann in finnland heute in schweden
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg sucht
nach einer lösung für die
unstimmigkeiten mit der türkei über
einen nato beitritt der beiden länder
stoltenberg sagte er heiße es willkommen
dass schweden bereits damit begonnen
habe seine anti terror gesetzgebung zu
ändern
ministerpräsidentin anders sollen
versicherte die türkischen
sicherheitsbedenken im kampf gegen den
terrorismus würden ernst genommen
der krieg russlands gegen die ukraine
hat ja auf vielen ebenen auch
wirtschaftliche folgen dass sich
deutschland im energiesektor von
russland endgültig unabhängig machen
will
in ostdeutschland besonders stark zu
spüren sein von den öl pipelines in
mecklenburg vorpommern bis zur
raffinerie im brandenburgischen schwedt
bei einem treffen mit den ostdeutschen
ländern versprach olaf scholz heute
solidarität vom bund und äußerte die
hoffnung dass der osten bei den
erneuerbaren energien künftig eine
führende rolle spielen werde solche
hoffnungen gibt es nicht nur für den
energiesektor auch bei anderen
zukunftstechnologien werben die
ostdeutschen länder für sich und können
auch erfolge verbuchen beispiel sachsen
anhalt von dort berichtet andreas weise
noch ist es ein kartoffelacker am
südwestlichen stadtrand von magdeburg
und doch die hoffnung einer ganzen
region hier auf einer fläche von 450
hektar will der chiphersteller intel
zwei werke bauen ab 2027 soll dann
produziert werden wie konzernchef
gelsinger bei der präsentation der pläne
verkündete
in phase eins wollen wir 17 milliarden
euro investieren um 2 platter fabriken
zu bauen die es so noch nicht gibt in
magdeburg der hauptstadt von sachsen
anhalt
so ähnlich wie auf diesen bildern aus
ohio soll es dann in magdeburg aussehen
die elbestadt setzte sich gegen
innerdeutsche konkurrenz aus sachsen und
bayern durch weil die verantwortlichen
von stadt und land auf allen ebenen auch
im persönlichen gespräch überzeugen
konnten wir haben zum ausdruck gebracht
dass wir dringend diese investitionen
nicht nur wollen sondern als chance
sehen dass wir den investor herzlich
willkommen heißen dass intel sich nicht
nur wohlfühlen wird sondern wir
gemeinsam wege beschreiten die auch zu
einer neuen situation führt auch im
lande und damit ein projekt intercity
entstehen kann was sozusagen eine
dynamik für eine gesamte region und
darüber hinaus entwickeln wird für
magdeburg ein zeichen des aufbruchs
industrieller niedergang daran hatte die
stadt lange zu kauen
oft sieht man sie noch die alten
verlassenen fabrikhallen wie dino
skelette erinnern sie an die alte fast
verschwundene schwerindustrie nun soll
durch intel der große bus kommen der der
stadt schon jetzt viel abverlangt
wir müssen jetzt schnell sein wir müssen
die bedingungen erfüllen und intel aber
auch die müssen jetzt auch in einer von
geschwindigkeit einen antrag stellen für
eine baugenehmigung die wahrscheinlich
aktenordner von einem lkw ausmachen wird
um alle facetten soll es damit zu
beantworten also beide parteien müssen
jetzt unheimlich schnell arbeiten 3000
hightech arbeitsplätze sollen so erstmal
entstehen mehr als 10.000 möglich sein
sicher auch die eu und bundesregierung
in mittlerer einstelliger milliardenhöhe
haben intel die entscheidung was
leichter gemacht
das ist eine subvention aber eine die
uns eben unabhängiger macht von anderen
weltregionen und die zu tarifvertraglich
gut bezahlten arbeitsplätzen führt und
sich deswegen über die nächsten jahre
auch wieder das geld geht da rein geholt
wird viel positives nicht nur in
magdeburg im ganzen osten das bestätigt
auch bundeswirtschaftsminister habe
heute auf dem ostdeutschen
wirtschaftsforum nun ist fehlten die
großen firmen sitze es fehlten die
großen
strukturen also wissenschaft und
forschungsstrukturen
das ändert sich jetzt die namen sind
natürlich legende große
automobilhersteller deutsche mit
bayerischer herkunft verlegen ihre
batteriefertigung hierher intel in
magdeburg tesla in brandenburg und so
steht ein acker im südwesten magdeburgs
für die mögliche wiedergeburt der
gesamten industrie region ostdeutschland
und mit wirtschaft geht es auch bereits
weiter am deutschen aktienmarkt ging es
für den dax heute weiter deutlich
abwärts gründe werden der ganze reihe
genannt von zinserwartungen bis
rezessionsängsten frank bethmann der
aktienmarkt und die deutsche wirtschaft
insgesamt wie ist die lage einzuschätzen
ja die minen verfinstern sich zusehends
immer neue schlechte nachrichten kommen
hinzu als wären die energiepreise nicht
schon genug gestiegen fürchten
rohstoffexperten dass das ende der
fahnenstange beim rohöl noch nicht
erreicht ist aktuell kostet das fass
über 120 dollar könnte demnach aber
weiter auf 140 bis 150 dollar steigen
und damit sogar die hohen ölpreise zu
beginn des ukraine krieges in den
schatten stellen die anhaltende teuerung
der krieg in europa dazu drohende neue
corona lockt da uns in china der
internationale währungsfond reagiert der
iwf sieht sich nach allem was man hört
gezwungen seine prognose abermals zu
korrigieren
für deutschland erwartet er in diesem
jahr nur noch ein wachstum von unter
zwei prozent
der dax setzt seine talfahrt fort
verliert auch heute über 2,4 prozent und
landet am ende bei nur noch
13.400 27 zählern angesichts stark
steigender preise zuletzt auch in den
usa befürchten die börsianer dass die us
notenbank in den kommenden tagen die
leitzinsen weiter deutlich anheben wird
was im kampf gegen die inflation helfen
soll steigende zinsen droht jedoch die
weltweite konjunktur abzuwürgen frank
bethmann vielen dank gerne
nach einer umfrage des paritätischen
gesamtverbandes haben viele kitas in
deutschland weiterhin mit personalmangel
zu kämpfen etwa die hälfte der
beschäftigten von einrichtungen und
deren trägern gab an dass die kapazität
ihrer kita nicht voll genutzt werden
kann weil fachkräfte fehlen aus der
sicht von 67 prozent der befragten gibt
es zu wenige kita plätze auf kommunaler
ebene und 60 prozent der befragten
erzieherinnen und erzieher sagten sie
können den bedürfnissen der kinder nicht
gerecht werden weil personal fehlt
bei der para schwimm-wm auf madeira hat
anja scholz die erste deutsche
goldmedaille geholt die
querschnittgelähmte elmshornerin gewann
in ihrer paradedisziplin über 100 meter
freistil vor den schwimmerinnen aus
brasilien und nur gut eine halbe stunde
später holte sie auch noch silber über
die 150 meter lagenstrecke ein starkes
wm debüt der 37-jährige
die deutsche fußball nationalmannschaft
die zuletzt vier mal unentschieden
gespielt hat geht morgen in ihre letzte
spiel vor der sommerpause in der nations
league gegen italien zu sehen im zdf ab
20 15 beim training heute konnte
bundestrainer flick alle 25 spieler des
kaders versammeln alle fit
das abschlusstraining in budapest war
nicht ganz so anstrengend doch die zeit
der sieglosigkeit macht keinen spaß man
könnte auch sagen viermal reni das tut
weh mir tun die vier unentschieden ja
ich finde es einfach nicht gut ja warum
das mal milde auszudrücken weil ich
gewinnen möchte und ich denke vielen
spielern im team geht es genauso das
vierte spiel in zehn tagen zu hause
gegen den europameister soll jetzt
bringen was bislang fehlte dieser
panisch hat einfach gefehlt dass wir
irgendwie ein erfolgserlebnis zusammen
erleben dass uns das so ein bisschen
mehr nach vorne bringt mit einem sieg
gegen italien könnte das team auf platz
1 der nations league gruppe in die
sommerpause gehen
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht es den montagskino weiter
und um 0.10 gibt es dann unter os x
update mit also an guckte mir und wir
melden uns morgen wieder in der halbzeit
bis dahin auf wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
gegen abend jetzt kommt die hitze zu uns
die ist heute schon hier über der
iberischen halbinsel gestartet wird zur
mitte der woche frankreich erreichen und
bis samstag gibt es dann sogar bei uns
an der nordseeküste recht hohe
temperatur vorher aber wird es noch mal
sehr kalt in dieser nacht in sauerland
sinken die temperaturen bis 4 grad dort
wird es also so kalt dass ich noch mal
ein nebel oder dunst bilden können im
nordosten sind einige wolkenfelder
unterwegs sind an der ostseeküste kann
es noch mal einen regenschauer geben und
auch morgen ziehen über den nordosten
noch einige wolken hinweg sonst aber
strahlt die sonne unter diesen dichteren
wolken nord außen da liegen die
höchsttemperaturen so bei 18 bis 23 grad
in der südwesthälfte geht es dagegen
schon auf 23 bis 29 grad rauf und dann
wird es von tag zu tag immer wärmer am
samstag erreichen dann die 22 bis 24
grad die küste und im binnenland
klettern die werte auf 29 bis 36 grad
dazu gibt es viel sonnenschein und
allenfalls am donnerstag an fronleichnam
kann es in den alpen und aus den alpen
heraus mal einen kurzen regenschauer
oder ein gewitter geben da droht jetzt
aber keine hitzewelle sondern es ist
eher ein hitze pik und sie sehen wann
der erreicht wird nämlich genau am
sommer wie sie hier am beispiel von
dresden sehen können da werden dann die
30 grad erreicht in freiburg im breisgau
sieht das ganz ähnlich aus allerdings
auf höherem niveau da werden sogar 35
grad erreicht mit diesen sommerlichen
aussichten wünsche ich ihnen jetzt einen
schönen abend